physicians among people aged 25
to 59 are increasing at an alarming rate
possibly as a result of highly
transmissible variants
and increased social mixing among
younger adults
today the emergency committee gave me
its advice on vaccines
variants international travel and other
issues
its full statement is available on our
website
we have the tools to bring this pandemic
under control
in a matter of months
if we apply them consistently and
equitably on friday
who issued an expression of interest for
establishing a covet 19 technology
transfer hub
for mrna vaccines to increase
production of those vaccines in low and
middle-income countries
we're calling for the original
manufacturers of
mrna vaccines to contribute their
technology and know how
and for manufacturers in low and
middle-income countries
to express interest in receiving that
technology
we have seen incredible innovation in
science
now we need innovation to ensure as many
people as possible benefit
from that science
the pandemic will recede but we will
still be left with all the
other challenges that we had before
including the climate crisis
this week marks thursday on the 22nd of
april
a reminder that human health depends on
the health of the planet
that sustains us covet 19
has now killed more than 3 million
people
air pollution kills more than
double that number seven million people
every single year
despite temporary improvements in air
quality
last year as a result of so-called
lockdowns
by september air pollution had returned
to pre-pandemic
levels globally
co2 emissions only decreased by less
than six percent last year
but by december they had rebounded to
their previous levels
the health argument for climate action
is crystal clear
the same unsustainable choices that are
killing our planet
are killing people
there is no vaccine for climate change
but we do have
solutions last year
who published our manifesto
for a healthy and green recovery calling
on all governments to protect nature
support clean energy sources develop
sustainable food systems and healthier
cities
and reduce polluting activities
together the six prescriptions of the
doubleh manifesto
can not only restore resilient economies
they are a linchpin and essential
prerequisite
for healthy societies
at the cop 2060 at the cop 26 climate
conference in glasgow this year
who will deliver a special report with
recommendations
on how to maximize the health benefits
of tackling climate change
while avoiding the worst health impacts
of the climate crisis
who is also spearheading an initiative
on promoting climate
resilient health systems in
collaboration with the government
of the united kingdom today
it's my honor to welcome someone
who needs no introduction
over the past few years greta tombe
has become the powerful voice of a
younger generation
demanding climate action
greatest mobilization of communities
particularly young people has been truly
inspirational
and has brought into sharp focus the
impact of the climate crisis
on people's lives and the urgent need
for transformative
action the awareness she has raised
on the links between climate the
environment
and health has supported who's agenda in
these areas
demonstrated the threats all of us face
and the role young people can play in
building
a more sustainable safer healthier
world more recently
she has become a powerful advocate for
vaccine equity
taxamike greta today
greta has announced a donation of
hundred thousand
euros from the greta tombe
foundation to the doubleh foundation in
support of
kovacs to provide vaccines to people
in need greta
thank you taxomike for your superb
advocacy
for climate action and now for vaccine
equity your contribution makes
the first and the youngest person to
contribute to kovacs
welcome and you have the floor
thank you so much for for having me it
is an honor to participate in this event
and i will yeah i will talk
briefly now and science shows that in
the future we will most likely
experience more frequent and more
devastating pandemics
unless we drastically changed the way
our ways and the way we treat nature
today
up to 75 of all emerging diseases
come from animals and as we are cutting
down forests and destroying habitats
we are creating the ideal conditions for
diseases to spill over from one animal
to another
and then to us and we can no longer
separate
the health crisis from the ecological
crisis and we cannot separate
separate the ecological crisis from the
climate crisis
it's all interlinked in many ways
and during this pandemic we have seen
what we can achieve when we put
resources
into science vaccines were developed in
record time
but so far on average one in four people
in high income countries
have received a coronavirus vaccine
compared with just
one in over 500 in low and middle income
countries
in the international community
governments and vaccine developments
must step up their game and address the
tragedy
that is vaccine inequity we have the
tools we need
to correct this great imbalance that
exists around the world today in the
fight against kobe 19.
just with the climate crisis those who
are the most vulnerable
need to be prioritized and global
problems require global solutions
it is completely unethical that
high-income countries
are now vaccinating young and healthy
people if that happens at the expense
of people in risk groups and on the
front lines in low and middle income
countries
and this is a moral test we talked today
about
showing solidarity and yet vaccine
nationalism
it's what's running the vaccine
distribution
it is only when it really comes down to
it that we show our true face
and that is why i and many others are
supporting who
garvey and all involved in the kovacs
initiative
which i believe offers the best path
forward to ensure a more equitable
global
vaccine distribution and a way out of
this pandemic
thank you
thank you thank you so much greta
and thank you for your generosity in
donating to the doubleh foundation in
support of kovacs
these funds will help us save lives
around the world young people have been
affected by the pandemic
in many ways from disruptions in
education
loss of employment opportunities mental
health
challenges and increased domestic and
gender-based violence
wha is committed to ensuring that the
global recovery from covet 19
includes the voices energy
and ideas of young people
to do that we have partnered with an
alliance of the six
largest youth development organizations
in the world to form the global youth
mobilization to empower young people to
respond to the challenges created
by the pandemic in their local
communities
the global youth mobilization has
established a grant mechanism
with funds from the solidarity response
fund
to support innovative local
solutions to address the impact of the
kobit 19 pandemic from today
young people around the world will be
able to apply for grants of between 500
and 5000 us dollars
through the global youth mobilization
this local solutions will be judged and
decided
on by young people for young people
to mark the starting point for young
people to get
involved in the global youth
mobilization
a global youth summit will be held
virtually
from this friday to sunday the 23rd
to the 25th of april
over three days thousands of young
people
leaders policy makers and change makers
will come together
in one space to discuss the issues
facing young people across
the world on behalf
of the big six youth organizations
the united nations foundation and who
i invite everyone to join us at the
global
youth summit today
i'm delighted to be joined by
representatives
from two of the big six organizations
first it's my honor to welcome
elahi raushan a volunteer with the
international federation of the red
cross
and red crescent societies in bangladesh
thank you for joining us today you have
the floor
uh thank you dr pedros for inviting me
here today
i'm really honored to be here my name is
ilahi roshan
i'm a retrospective youth volunteer
living in bangladesh
there are about 3 million young people
around the world
who have been taking action to respond
to the kovit 19 pandemic
driving the response efforts and
supporting their local communities
i would like to share with you my story
to help
explain why recognizing championing
and investing in young people
through the global youth mobilization is
important
i led the very first disinfection team
of bangladeshism society
in different hospitals for two
consecutive months
at the beginning of the pandemic here
the hospitals needed
more supporting hands and we wanted to
make sure
the hospital environments are safe for
everyone
and we did to a great extent
like one day when the very first covet
patient
died in a hospital and everyone was so
frightened to go near him
even his own son was reluctant to take
his father's body
we went in we disinfected the room and
made sure the body is safe for carrying
another day i carried a critical covet
patient
on a wheelchair put oxygen mask on her
when there was no one around for the
support of of that person
but i was not the only one there are
thousands of young people in bangladesh
fighting this battle in many different
forms
about 4500 young volunteers of the red
christian society
supporting the vaccination program every
day
in bangladesh it's mostly the young
people here
who are making a difference and again is
the young people here
who are mostly affected by the pandemic
many of my friends colleagues from the
different youth organizations and
networks
have lost their jobs almost everyone
here is suffering from mental health
issues
the data shows that from march 2020
to february 2021 more than 14
000 people have committed suicide which
is 45
percent higher than the previous year
and majority of them are young people
my dear friends i have seen localized
action
making a positive impact on people's
lives
during this pain damage i have been
trying to collaborate with the red
christian society with my
workplace brac who have been offering
skills program online skills program for
the young people
now both as both parties have agreed the
red crescent youth volunteers will
receive
a three-month online skills training on
different traits like graphics designing
web development etc
i believe drives like this will help
young people
individually and at the same time it
will contribute to the national economy
there are plenty of organizations and
individuals out there
who are making many more new initiatives
to combat this povich crisis
and i would like to invite them all to
collaborate with the global youth
mobilization
and it will support promote and invest
in your initiatives for improving
more lives and communities thank you
thank you thank you so much
next it's my pleasure to introduce daisy
morin a representative of the world ymca
and the board member of the global youth
mobilization
daisy thank you for joining us and you
have the floor
thank you for giving me this opportunity
dr ted rose
and greetings to you all i'm daisy moran
proud to be with the ymca in illinois
usa
and proud to be one of the six youth
board representatives
of the global youth mobilization here's
what
youth mobilization has meant for me as
the kobe pandemic has significantly
increased the inequities in all of our
societies
as a young leader i saw a need in my
community
to offer relief to essential workers who
are undocumented immigrants
through collaboration with fellow young
change makers and organizations
we were able to almost to disperse
almost 17 thousand dollars in relief
funds for 38 families
this is just one of thousands of stories
that
illustrate the simple and powerful fact
when given
access and opportunities young people
can make a significant
difference in the ymca and right across
the big six youth organizations
young people have stepped up during the
pandemic
by delivering supplies to vulnerable
people looking after each other's mental
health
making mass helping share vital public
information
and now actively facilitating the
coveted vaccine
campaign as the global pandemic enters
the recovery and relief period
it is crystal clear that young people
are disproportionately impacted
by the immediate and long-term
implications
of disruption in education employment
opportunities
physical and mental health well-being to
name a few
these two reasons young people bearing
the brunt of
impact of covid young people offering so
many of the solutions
are what has inspired the big six youth
organizations
the world health organization in the
united nations foundation
to support young people around the world
in delivering and developing
youth-led community solutions through
the global youth
mobilization i am so excited and i want
young people all over the world to be
excited and get involved
they can start by attending the global
youth summit which will be held
virtually
from the 23rd to the 25th of april
at the summit they will hear about the
role of young people in the immediate
and long-term coveted recovery
it's a great forum where we can share
our thoughts passions
ideas that will influence policies and
decisions that impact
all of our lives this is a critical time
for my generation for our generation
to bring policy makers change makers
advocates together to address the major
challenges
confronting young people find solutions
and put them
into action in our communities no matter
how big
or how small i encourage you to have the
confidence to apply for funding
if you have an idea to chat if you have
an idea
to a challenge created by the pandemic
you can apply for funding
from five hundred dollars to five
thousand dollars
it is young people like you and me that
will evaluate and agree
who get support for these local
solutions
so please visit our website www dot
global youth mobilization dot
org we are the movement by youth
for you and young people really are the
answer
we are not the challenge we are truly
being the change that we want to see in
the world
thank you
thank you thank you so much daisy by
youth for youth
and thank you to both of you for your
leadership and and vision
i look forward to joining both of you at
the world
youth summit and i look forward to
seeing what ideas we can help take
forward
through the global youth mobilization
this is a reminder that although we are
all living
through a dark time there are also many
reasons for hope
and optimism about the future
christian back to you
thank you very much all and thank you
very much dr tedros
we'll start the rounds of questions and
answers
to remind you if you want to get into
the cure for questions please press the
raise your hand icon on your
screen and we'll start with the first
question from
carlos from el mundo and carlos please
unmute yourself
yeah hi go ahead please
yeah yeah it's a question specifically
for for gretchen
and is is there a risk that the
cop 26 would lose the the momentum
and what should really change in the
next three
months for example to to change to turn
the tide and
and to to put the two goals of a
climate change and vaccination equality
at the same level
thank you very much carlos and yes
cradle timber please
yes i mean of course there's a risk that
that cop will lose momentum but the most
important thing is that everyone is safe
and of course safety and health comes
first in these kinds of situation
um so and of course there's not just one
thing that needs to change
in order to to break this this trend
that we are seeing now there's not just
one single thing that we can do to
so-called soul the climate crisis and
the vaccine
inequity crisis of course it's it's
a bit more complicated than that um
and i think i may not be the best person
to answer that i think there are
lots of experts that are more more
suited for that question but we do need
to change our mindsets we do need
to think globally and not only think for
ourselves
about ourselves that's what
these crises come down to that we only
think for ourselves that we don't think
about others
they come down to the way we treat
others the way we treat other human
beings
the way we treat other animals and
nature itself
so we need to change our mindsets
if if you want one simple thing it's
much it's more complicated
than that but if just one thing
thank you very much krita and i'll ask
dr marianera
from w jo to uh possibly
thank you christian and thank you very
much greta is
it's really a pleasure to have you with
us you are an inspiration you have been
driving an incredible movement and many
people is behind so certainly the cop
26 has to be something very successful
in response to your question
carlos ola i think
what will change the mindset and what
might have an
incredible impact is what our director
general was
saying at the beginning the health
argument of climate
change if we are able to explain people
that
climate change is about our health is
affecting our health
and if we stop to burn fossil fuels the
benefits will be enormous in terms of
reducing the causes of climate change
but as well on reducing air pollution
and air pollution
as mentioned again by the director
general is responsible for
more than seven premature million deaths
every year due to exposure to air
pollution and in addition to that
it creates an environment that makes our
health more
vulnerable and create the perfect
conditions for
more emerging infectious diseases to
occur so i think we have a perfect case
here for
creating more action at the at the cop
giving the health benefits that can be
obtained
in an incredible way if we tackle the
causes of air pollution if we tackle the
causes of climate change that will be an
enormous
health agenda in in talking about health
is what can
make this change that we all need in
terms of ambition
to to go for more at the cup and in
convincing people
if we go if we tell people that this is
connected to
the human health i think this will be
the the
final argument that will create much
more motivation and engagement and
probably
a stronger movement to put political
pressure on those who will take
decisions and hopefully
going for much more thank you
thank you very much this was dr
marianera
director for environment climate change
and
health the next question goes to shoko
koyama from nhk
please unmute yourself
hello can you hear me go ahead please
thank you for taking my question so
regarding the callbacks
uh unicef is trying to buy one billion
syringes by the end of this year in
order to distribute countries
together with vaccines um one billion
syringes in addition to six
to eight a hundred million smidges um
they procure annually seems to be a
large quantity
um is kovacs able to procure this huge
number of syringes by the end of the
year
and what challenges there are regarding
the procurement of
students assuming thank you
thank you very much and i'll give to
dr bruce elwood thank you very much
choco for the question and thanks for
highlighting that
it takes more to get the world
vaccinated than simply to
make and and and procure the vaccines
because there are all the additional
pieces that have to go into this
including additional supplies like not
just syringes that you mentioned but
also
the vaccination coal chains and other
supplies that are necessary to keep them
in the right conditions before we
get them to the actual people who need
to be vaccinated
in terms of the syringes just like the
the coal chain equipment the kovacs
facility began
working with countries way back in
october even earlier last year
to look at what numbers of syringes
would be required and to start working
with manufacturers to ensure that
pipeline would be there
you might remember some months ago the
director general invited henrietta for
who is the who is the head the executive
director of unicef
to to join one of these press
conferences and at that time she
explained what they were already doing
to try
and make sure that the necessary
syringes would be in place
now this will continue to be a challenge
just like all of the supplies necessary
to get the world vaccinated these
extraordinary numbers
but for the moment the pipelines are
there and the producers
are doing their part but you know it all
comes back
again also to the kovacs facility having
the resources it needs so that it can
put the contracts in place
up front to make sure the supplies are
there not just the supplies in terms of
the vaccines but exactly like you
highlight
the syringes and the other supplies
including as i mentioned
the cold chain equipment and sometimes
very specialized cold chain equipment
to get these products to people
thank you very much dr ellwood and we'll
move on to robin mia from afp ramen
please
unmute yourself
thank you a question for greta if i may
if vaccine inequity carries on and young
people start being offered a vaccine in
wealthy countries
whilst at the same time elderly
vulnerable people
remain completely unprotected in poor
countries
would you advocate a vaccine strike
amongst younger people in rich countries
until their government starts sharing
more vaccines thank you
thank you very much roma and of course
kirita
floor is yours yes we must not forget
that this is not a problem that is
caused by
individuals this is a problem that needs
to be addressed by the international
community
government and the vaccine developers
um it is wrong if we should start
focusing on individuals
and urging individuals to not take the
vaccine that would send the very wrong
message
of course everyone who who is offered a
vaccine should take it
but this is we need to see the bigger
picture here
and be able to focus on several things
at once
so no i would not advocate for people to
not take the vaccine
thank you so much for that and we'll
move to jamil shad
from oestado de sao paulo jamil please
unmute yourself
do you hear us please unmute yourself
can you hear me question please go ahead
can you hear me yes yes thank you
uh this is ramirez joining us from
brazil
miss greta zumba my question is about
vaccines but also on climate change what
is your message
to president bolsonaro at this time
when both the pandemic is hitting hard
brazil
but also climate change is an issue and
you all
you'll know very well what is the
position of of president bolsonaro what
is the message you can send him
today thank you thank you so much jamil
and over to greta
of course i don't think we should be
focusing on
talking about individuals since this is
a much larger problem
but of course uh chao bolsonaro has a
huge responsibility both when it comes
to the climate
environment and of course we can see the
response that brazil has had during the
corona pandemic
and of course you can i think
well i can only speak for myself but i
can safely say that
he has failed to take the responsibility
that is necessary to in order to to save
god
present and future living conditions for
for humanity
thank you very much kirita and we'll
move on to another shah from
xinhua namaste please unmute yourself
another char do you hear us please admit
yourself
now it looks like we're not getting to
use and we continue with gunila van gaal
from
swenska dark blooded canela please
unmute yourself
yes can you hear me wonderful go ahead
thanks a lot thanks for taking my
question it is too greater
tinberg and i'd like to know your view
on the proposal from who and many
governments among those your own the
swedish government
that richer countries should donate
remaining vaccine doses to poorer
countries
once their own risk groups have been
vaccinated and before
they vaccinate the rest of the
population what do you think about this
and what do you respond to people
questioning this saying
why should we sacrifice our own
populations in order to save
the world thank you
thank you canila over to greta please
i think that is a very reasonable thing
to do
we need to protect the people we need to
protect and prioritize the most
vulnerable people in risk groups and
working on the front lines
no matter which countries they come from
at least that's my opinion
and of course i understand that people
will be frustrated by that
of course i also want to return to it to
everyday life and
everyone i know uh want to do that as
well but
but we need to to act in solidarity and
we need to use common sense
um when it comes to these issues and for
that i think that we
like i said it's the only sensible thing
to do the only morally right thing to do
is to prioritize the people who are the
most vulnerable
um no matter whether whether they live
in a high-income country
or a low-income country
thank you very much miss sundereck
and we'll move ahead to jamie keaton
from
ap jamie please admit yourself
thank you uh thank you christian um my
question is
uh both for ms dunberg and uh ms
moran um what is your message
to young people who have become a major
driver
of covid19 infections we heard dr
director general tedros just mentioned
that in
increased social mixing among younger
adults
is possibly one of the reasons for the
increase
in infections and hospitalizations among
people age 25 to
59. and if i could just uh sneak in
another question to miss
simberg ahead of president biden's
climate
summit what do you hope it will achieve
thank you
no small questions today thank you very
much jamie let's move to greta
of first and then on
thank you
yes of course it's absolutely crucial
that everyone takes our personal
responsibility in this crisis
we young people may be the the ones who
who are least affected by in general
least affected by
the virus in a direct way but
of course that's like i said we need to
act in solidarity
with the people in risk groups and and
of course many young people
fail to draw that connection maybe and
of course not everyone
but of course there will always be some
and my message to those
is that we need during crisis like this
we need to
to take a few steps back and act for the
greater good
of society and in order to protect our
fellow citizens
and and then of course
especially people in risk groups because
that is the thing
you do during crises you you
you step up for for one another
and my hopes for the biden summit is um
i hope that we will start soon in one
way or another start treating this
crisis
like a crisis the climate crisis that is
because
if if we are to be blunt i mean we can
have as many summits as we want we can
have as many meetings and conferences as
we want
and talk make nice speeches and nice
pledges
like net zero 2050 and so on but
as long as we as long as those things
contain so many loopholes as they do and
as long as we are really not
as long as we are not actually treating
the crisis like a crisis
of course we won't be able to achieve
any major changes
like i mentioned earlier this is
something that we need we need
to change our mindsets and we need to
change our view of the world we cannot
move into this try to solve this crisis
with the same
approach that got us into it in the
first place
so we need we need to start treating the
crisis like a crisis
without increased level of awareness
among people in general of course there
will be no pressure on world leaders to
actually
start making the changes that are
necessary to safeguard
humanity so
my hope is that we will start treating
the crisis like a crisis
thank you so much kirita and let me
first give the floor to daisy
moran from the global youth mobilization
youth board
daisy thank you and thank you for your
question
i believe my generation our generation
that we
are representing is a generation of
allyship because we understand our
privilege and how to use our privileges
to uplift those in the most vulnerable
situations
and the global youth summit is a
platform and a forum
for all of youth and stakeholders and
supporters to come together
to really listen to what are the policy
changes that need to be made
so that we can have more equitable
societies and systems in place
so i hope that you can join us this
weekend while we discuss
the important issues and challenges
facing our generation
and how our youth leaders are in a
position to create the most innovative
solutions
to tackle these big issues thank you
thanks so much daisy and i'll move to dr
maria van kerkov
thanks christian and i just wanted to
those were excellent answers but i did
want to clarify
something here with regards to increased
transmission
we are seeing increased rates of
infection across all age groups
last week there were 5.2 million
cases reported to who globally the
largest in a single week
since this pandemic began 16 months into
the pandemic that is the largest
increase in a week
that we have seen to date we've seen an
increase across all age groups
this virus is not being we shouldn't we
need to take the blame
away and in the question it was meant to
blame
and we can't do that everyone has a role
to play in this pandemic we all have a
role to play in keeping ourselves
and our loved ones safe what we are
seeing is an age shift a slight age
shift in some countries
driven by social mixing and social
mixing doesn't
necessarily mean going out and having a
party
it means individuals who have to leave
their home to go to work
it means individuals who have to feed
their families
and if you increase social mixing for a
variety of reasons
whether this is for work or whether this
is for religious reasons or whether this
is for
indeed socializing itself the virus will
take advantage of that
if you add on top of it these variants
of concern
variants that are circulating around the
world particularly the b117 variant
which is circulating in a large number
of countries across the globe
they have increased transmissibility if
you add
variants that have increased
transmissibility with increased mixing
this virus will take off and case
numbers will
increase in a number of countries we've
seen a very
very steep incline due to this in
addition to that we are seeing
some countries not able to implement the
social the public health and social
measures
that are needed to allow for physical
distancing and in many parts of the
world physical distancing
is really not possible but in other
parts of the world it is so we need to
do what we can to avoid those crowded
settings
avoid those uh settings where social
mixing particularly in indoor
crowded settings where there's poor
ventilation where the virus
really likes to spread efficiently
between individuals
we need governments to enable people to
carry out those measures
very easy for us to say stay home if you
can but we need governments to support
individuals to work from home
to stay home if necessary so that we
could reduce the possibility of the
virus to spread
all of us really have a role to play
youth young people
children young adults are showing us
ways in which to be innovative to remain
socially connected
yet physically distant and i think what
we are seeing with
the youth in this youth mobilization is
really
energetic there's a spirit there's an
energy here that is holding leaders
accountable and saying help
us help the situation and i'm really
inspired to see
that i i was really happy to hear the by
youth for youth as you've pointed out
and showing us that
young people young adults children
can make a significant difference every
day so please let's stop the blame
in terms of who is spreading all of us
have a role to play
all of us need to be supported in taking
those individual level measures
as well as measures at the family at the
community
at the sub-national at the national and
at the international level
thanks so much dr van kerkov and i'll
have dr mike ryan
who um health emergencies
executive director
thanks christian i just want to reflect
on one thing that daisy said
she said the youths are not the problem
youth are the solution
and i fundamentally believe in that uh
and thank you daisy for saying that
and the energy from from everyone today
is fantastic uh
reflecting on something that greta said
she spoke about mindset
and mindset is everything and ted ross
reminds us of that every day i think
it's one of his most
common uh pronouncements about mindset
and it doesn't matter what problem
you're trying to solve
there's no amounts of announcements
there are no amounts of rep there's no
amount of recommendations
there's no amount of anything that
changes anything until we change our
mindset
and that could be the mindset about
protecting ourselves and our families
from covet
and taking precautions it can be the
mindset on
on government's response to um to covert
it can be
the mindset driving climate action
and and reducing climate change so i i
think
really really we all need to reflect on
that it is our mindsets that drive our
behaviors both positive
and negative and they're having a huge
impact on our planet
and obviously our behavior is having a
huge impact on the trajectory of this
pandemic
thank you thank you very much dr ryan
next question in line comes from isabel
sako from
fa isabel please unmute yourself
good afternoon thank you thank you
christian
um i would like to know if you could
give us an
overview of the proportion of people
under 40
years old who are in icus globally or we
or in orbit regions and connected to
that
what do we know about mortality among
babies
i saw figures from brazil that indicates
that 1 300 babies
have died there from covets
thank you thank you very much isabelle
very detailed questions let me
give to dr mayor from chiako first yeah
thanks for the thanks for these very
important questions i cannot give you a
specific answer of the proportion of
those under 40 in icu but what i can say
is that there is an increasing number of
hospitalizations
among younger individuals and this is
driven by what i answered in the last
part of the question was
when you have increased transmissibility
across all age groups
you will see increased rates of
hospitalization you will see
increased proportion of icu and you will
see increases in death
and we are seeing unfortunately a little
bit of a shift
in the age structure in terms of the the
median age of individuals who are
infected
but that is driven by changes in social
mixing patterns
if you remember last spring in the
northern hemisphere spring
we actually saw a similar uh similar
situation
where as societies were opening up
across europe for example
the aid there was an age shift in the
median age it went from an older age
group to a slightly younger age group
again this is driven by people who are
leaving their homes to go back to work
and if there is the virus that is
spreading if you have virus variants
this is a dangerous combination we are
seeing increases in hospitalization
among younger age groups and increased
icu and increased deaths
with regards to children i did see that
report that you had mentioned about in
brazil
overall if we look at infection
among children if we look at severity
among children
still around the world there is a lower
proportion of children that
experience disease that experience
severe disease
and some children do die if there is a
lot of virus that is circulating if you
have
you know millions of cases that are
being reported and you know so far we've
had 140 million cases reported worldwide
we will see deaths in all age groups
with regards to the youngest
children overall they tend to be more
mild
but again this is not universal we do
see that children
particularly children with underlying
conditions but children in general
have died from covid so everyone is at
risk from this virus
people are at risk of getting infected
at risk of getting severe disease so we
do
need to do what we can where we can as
much as we can
to first and foremost prevent infections
but
also that making sure that we use the
systems that are in place to get tested
to be able to carry out the public
health actions that do
prevent the spread from an adult to a
child from a child to an adult
everything that we can to really prevent
that that level of infection and care
for for as
many people as we can getting them early
into that clinical care pathway to
receive
the care based on the symptoms that they
have
thank you so much next question goes to
aquazi sarpong from
bbc north africa akwasi please unmute
yourself
a quasi do you hear us yes please go
ahead
the quasi the sound is really bad please
try this
in ghana so it's not
so these are questions i have two
questions i like many young people
living with disability particularly
visual impairment
impairment have been affected by these
virus
in africa and at a global level the
second question is that
what programs are in place to support
families
with children and young persons with
disabilities
and special needs to help us combat this
thank you thank you very much it was a
very important question here and
i'll hand to dr frank kerkel for a start
i can actually start in fact we have
departments that are working
particularly on persons with
disabilities to ensure that persons
with disabilities who are
disproportionately affected by covenant
19 in a variety of ways
whether this is about getting the right
care receiving
information appropriately so that they
know how to keep themselves safe making
sure that they have the ability to
receive
the materials the needs the testing et
cetera
we have some guidance that is coming out
i hope
today it was approved yesterday
looking specifically at the more than
one billion
people worldwide who are living with
disabilities
making sure that they have access to
vaccinations for example
we have seen some innovation in terms of
personal protective equipment if you
if you've noticed some of the masks for
example will have a clear
panel so that you can see lips moving
for people who
have a hearing impairment and so there
are a number of innovations that are
coming online to support
individuals with disabilities but also
families with disabilities as well
because
even individuals with disabilities their
caretakers have to be able to care for
them
so we need to make sure that those
caregivers are protected
against the virus as well so there's a
number of activities that are underway
to ensure those living with disabilities
as well as those caring for disabilities
have the appropriate care information
that they need
thank you very much dr frank kirkov next
question goes to pritipatnik from
geneva health files pretty please unmute
yourself
no pretty low the hand apparently in the
meantime where we don't find you anymore
then the next question goes to john
sarah costas from the lancer john please
admit yourself
yes good afternoon can you hear me there
very well go ahead
yes yes i was wondering if you could
give me
up-to-date estimates on how many
vaccine facilities worldwide with excess
capacity could be enabled to produce
vaccines and secondly if it's possible
if dr tedros can give us his perspective
on what's going on in his homeland
where right now they're facing an
existential threat
thank you very much we'll take the first
question
um and i guess we'll try if mariangela
seemaw is online
more than i could i could start
dr swami natan exactly please go ahead
thank you thank you very much john for
that question
this is exactly the work that we've
started now as part of the
covid vaccine manufacturing task force
with our kovacs partners
sepi gavi unicef as well as the private
sector
and regional bodies like the african
union but also regional
other regional uh organizations the idea
really is to take a
short a medium term and a longer term
approach the
short-term and immediate need is to
increase vaccine
supplies within the next weeks and
months
and that can be done by unblocking
roadblocks and obstacles that are that
have been identified by the
manufacturers
and by working with suppliers of those
critical ingredients and raw materials
so that we can link suppliers and and
manufacturers as well as work with
member states to make sure that
export bans and things like that don't
interfere with the process of vaccine
manufacturing
so that's our immediate short-term
priority
which hopefully will will be able to
put more doses uh to go backs for kovacs
in the coming weeks the second more
medium term is to look at
fill and finish capacity to link us we
know that there's a lot of
unused fill and finish capacity globally
and
therefore we need manufacturers who have
the capacity to make bulk product
and link them with these existing fill
and finish
capacities in facilities around the
world so sepi already has
done a mapping of that and it exists and
and then the third more medium to longer
term is really to develop
um new facilities or to build on
existing facilities particularly in low
and middle income countries
and get technology transfer encourage
companies as the dg mentioned the who
put out a call on friday
both for owners of technology
particularly
mrna technology to begin with to come
forward to work with us
to share that technology share the
know-how and experience
with recipient companies that will be
selected according to a set of criteria
that
that we are developing and this will
ensure not only supplies for
this pandemic though it may take you
know a few months to get this
up and running if we start with existing
facilities with some expertise
but also will help the future regional
health security
of regions which currently do not have
any manufacturing capacity
and this obviously can be extended to
vaccines for many other infectious
diseases
so that's what the task force is looking
at and over the coming days
we will provide much more detail thank
you
thank you so much dr swaminathan and i'm
calling for
on dr mike ryan to take the other part
um yes uh thank you john
uh important question uh the situation
in
in tigre in ethiopia uh
remains very very dire at the moment uh
we have
a situation is not improving we have
unpredictable access
increasing humanitarian needs uh
increasing sexual
violence uh the response has been
hindered by armed clashes throughout the
region
and many areas are still not receiving
food or other assistance
we've got 4.5 million people affected by
this
crisis 2.5 million of them have no
access to services whatsoever
to half a million of people have no
access to food
we have a million internally displaced
people in 178 sites scattered across the
region
being serviced by iom and unhcr we've
had
over 800 cases of sexual and
gender-based violence
from just five hospitals alone from
reporting from five hospitals
and that many cases we've over 62 000
refugees
that have crossed into sudan but that's
uh that
safety valve is very very difficult to
manage and very difficult
for trust to have access from that side
and to support
people in the affected area so as i said
unpredictable access
displacement tremendous humanitarian
needs we
we have 20 health partners working with
us or operational on the ground
but they're only accessing about half of
the world rate is
concerned and when we look at health
facilities we've done a
health facility survey throughout the
region 264 health systems
as of now only 72 of those facilities
are operational
or operational and and 40 of those
are only partially accessible 19
hospitals have been completely damaged
or destroyed
15 more with major damage there's
inadequate supply chains across the
board
so the situation integra could not be
more dire
the people there could not be in more
need of support
and help the situation is deteriorating
the situation is very much a massive
concern
on a purely humanitarian basis here
there is a health crisis on top
of the humanitarian crisis we're very
concerned about malnutrition but malaria
about cholera
measles cod19 positivity rates have been
rising
and other diseases like meningitis and
other diseases that will exploit
malnutrition they will exploit stress
and they will exploit
all of what's happening in that
population we have resumed surveillance
activities but
only in about covering about 30 percent
of the population
and again severe acute malnutrition is a
major
major issue it is very hard to overstate
the extent
of the humanitarian crisis and the
health crisis currently unfolding
in tigre um and the
who and the other un agencies and ngos
are calling for unfettered humanitarian
access
and for uh for um for
military conflict and those perpetrating
that conflict
to remove themselves uh from humanity
from civilian areas
and those who should not be there should
not be there thank you
thank you very much this was dr mcgrein
executive director for wgl's health
emergencies program
and dr bruce ellwood wanted to come in
thanks christian i just wanted to come
back to the point the important point
john you raised about
the additional how much capacity is
unused around the world right now
because there's a huge attention last
week with the
conference of the african union the
consultation that was called by the
world trade organization about trying to
expand vaccine production globally
but we need to remember that the
challenge is how we're actually using
the doses that are being made
because last week while those
conferences were taking place
100 more million more doses of vaccine
were administered around the world and
the issue john is where they're being
administered because
one percent of that hundred million went
to low income countries
so 99 million doses of vaccines last
week
went into high upper middle income and
some low middle income countries but
only one percent of that went to the
lowest income countries
so every time we bring new capacities
online when we bring new deals online
etc that you're hearing about we need to
ask the question of where those doses
are going because those doses are not
going to the places that have got the
least vaccine today
so we need to be careful in thinking
that we can
simply build additional capacity because
that capacity
is still going to the wrong places quite
frankly
so while we are giving great attention
to how do we expand
capacity it's going to take weeks and
months for that to come on
online and in the meantime we've got to
take some you know
urgent and important decisions about how
we're going to use the vaccines that
exist today
because if we have a lot more weeks
where 100 you know 99
of the vaccine goes to a set of
countries that already have most of the
vaccine
we are not going to get out of this
crisis
as rapidly and efficiently and with his
least
you know lives lost as possible
thank you very much for all your answers
uh with this you're coming to the
end of our question and answer session
i was very glad to have you all online
today and our special guest and i will
ask actually our special guest
to start the closing round and we'll go
in
reverse order we'll start with daisy
moran
from the global youth mobilization youth
board and world ymca representative
daisy please
go ahead thank you for the opportunity
once again
and as a reminder please join us this
weekend
on april 23rd through the 25th to have
your voice heard
youth have the solutions please come to
the table
we want you to be involved in your local
communities and we have the funds to
support you
with any questions please visit our
website at
www.youthglobalmobilization.org
thank you fantastic thanks so much
and now we go to eli roshan volunteer
from the
international federation of the red
cross and christian societies
and supporting the young people in
bangladesh
please go ahead
thank you i would like to thank everyone
for inviting me here
and i would like to echo my last voice
young people at the solution
and i would like to uh invite all the
localized solutions to
collaborate with the global youth
mobilization who have been supporting
these local actions and promoting
them so i would also like to invite
everyone to join the global youth summit
coming up this week
from 23rd to 25th thank you once again
and thank you so much a lie to you
and last but not least we go to greater
homburg climate
and environmental activist krita floor
is yours
well to be honest i don't really have
anything more to add just take care
everyone
and well yeah
but also when when we have media here i
really urge you
to really bring awareness to this issue
of vaccine inequity
because you have the power to to raise
awareness about this and when we
when we talk about like um countries
like for example the uk
in the us just as a few examples that
they are
mass vaccinating large groups of their
populations
even healthy and young people that we
that we see it
from from a different perspective that
we don't only
see it from our western privileged point
of view
but rather that we think globally and we
need to prioritize
those most vulnerable posts yeah
thank you take care everyone
thank you so much creator for these
words and
yes there's hardly anything to add i
agree
from my side let me thank everyone and
remind you that the
the sound files of this press briefing
will be shared right afterwards
today and the transcript will be
available as of
tomorrow talk to terrorists
thank you thank you christian so i would
like to
thank our guests today to greta
ellahi and daisy you have been wonderful
thank you so much indeed
and i would also like to join you in
inviting everybody to join the
23rd to 25th global youth summit from
friday to sunday
so look forward to seeing you there
and i would like also like to i would
also like to thank
our media colleagues who have
joined and see you in our upcoming
presser that will be on friday
so thank you thank you so much
you